hi this is Dr Gregory Sadler I'm a
professor of philosophy and the
president and founder of an educational
consulting company called reason I O
where we put philosophy into practice
I've studied and taught Philosophy for
over 20 years and I find that many
people run into difficulties reading
classic philosophical texts
sometimes it's the way things are said
or how the text is structured
but the concepts themselves are not
always that complicated and that's where
I come in
to help students and lifelong Learners
I've been producing longer lecture
videos and posting them to YouTube many
viewers say they find them useful
what you're currently watching is part
of a new series of shorter videos each
of them focused on One Core concept from
an important philosophical text I hope
you find it useful as well
there are several passages in book Seven
of Marcus aurelius's meditations that
have to do with what we could feel
instead of getting angry with other
people when they screw up or even when
they do things that maybe they intend to
hurt us or that we feel are in some way
offending us or damaging us or hurting
us and I think we should start with 26
where
one way of translating it when people
injure you but a little bit more broadly
and literally when somebody screws up
when somebody does wrong hamarte right
so hamartia means everything from error
and mistake to sin when somebody sins
against you when they do something that
they shouldn't do to you then you can do
certain things and what Marcus is
actually recommending to us is a a
course of thinking a way of approaching
these matters that will allow us
ultimately to feel we could translate it
as pity sympathy compassion uh Elise and
this is actually in the future so he's
saying if you do this then you will in
fact feel pity towards the the person
who's screwing up in place of what in
place of marveling or here's another
interesting translation outrage rather
than being outraged at them and that's
coming from the word to wonder to be an
awe to to be surprised by thalmanzan or
getting angry with them right you will
not get angry with them when that would
be your natural tendency to be like what
the hell is going on here that's the
marveling and then I better do something
about this that's getting angry right so
instead of that you can look at the
other person sympathetically now the
question is
how do you do that what do you have to
tell yourself ask yourself remind
yourself in order to do that so he says
the language here is really quite Rich
ask and the thumbu put it into your
heart put it into your part of yourself
that cares about things you're literally
your thumos are the part that gets angry
right ask
how these people get things wrong how do
they go astray how do they screw up
in their assumptions
is the term that's used in a technical
way in Philosophy for making assumptions
and what are they making assumptions
about what they're doing and whether it
is going to produce good things or bad
things so maybe they're assuming that
they're doing harm to you and they're
actually mistaken about that if they are
indeed not able to do harm to you but
they want to do it right and why the
hell would they want to harm you because
they've got screwed up assumptions they
don't understand
what it is that we human beings are
supposed to do how we're supposed to be
in relation to each other they think
it's a good thing to say bully somebody
else or you know humiliate somebody else
or interfere with them in some way and
you know you could say to yourself well
you poor bastard right and not in the
sense of putting them down but in the
sense of feeling pity for them you you
know you remind yourself that they're
doing what they're doing because that's
what seems the right thing to do for
them right and you should then think he
says about your own assumptions
are your assumptions as he says are your
assumptions the same as theirs or near
them your assumptions about Good and
Evil
if that's the case well then you should
actually excuse them right because they
actually they're just doing the same
thing that you're doing and the word
here is quite interesting uh so so
gignos gain right which we get the words
which has a sense not just of excusing
but even forgiving
being willing to let things slide so you
know if they've got the same screwed up
assumptions that we do why are we
actually complaining about that maybe we
should spend more time fixing ourselves
but if they differ if if we've got our
heads on straight and they don't then we
can now the translation here is a little
bit misleading
um
they deserve your compassion if your
sense of Good and Evil is different from
theirs it doesn't actually say
compassion as such another way of
translating this you Menace is be
gracious to them be be decent to them
treat them like human beings even though
they're messed up be peaceful with that
as another way of saying it because
they're they're going astray right
um they are getting things they're
they're literally looking at things in
the wrong way so you know if we practice
this there's a good chance for us to
maybe not
avoid anger every single time but
certainly feel less of it and maybe even
transfer that anger that energy into
um feeling compassion feeling pity
towards these other people
I I think that uh chapter 63 helps us
see a wider extent to this as well
there's some additional you know
Reflections that are along these lines
Every Soul he says is cut off stereotype
right or deprived
um has a lack that's that's the steracis
is a privation or lack so every soul
that's lacking
um you know truth is doing so
unwillingly not by its own choice now
you could say well it's a product of
your own damn choices you stupid person
you didn't read the books that you
should have or you chose to take an
obstinate stance sure sure
but
on some level it is still involuntary
why did they choose to do that we go
back to 26 they have wrong-headed
conceptions of good and bad right they
think it's good for them to not study or
practice or anything like that and so
they wind up being cut off from truth
and not just from truth also from these
virtues like justice or self-control you
know so frosune which we can translate
as Temperance and also from kindness
right and we see this same term right
Humanes humanea being kind being gentle
with other people they're cut off from
that unwillingly and so he tells us it
tells himself and then they're there for
us it is absolutely
necessary
you can't have any stronger uh way of
framing things than that to continually
keep this in mind to remind ourselves
to remember to be mindful of what what
do we need to be mindful of the fact
that people are cut off from truth and
these other characteristics unwillingly
and then what'll happen well you'll be
more patient or gentle
this is coming from the word praus which
is the opposite you could say of anger
right
all these other terms are being angry
prowse means not being angry or at least
in some respects being angry at the
right time for the right reason the
stoics don't think that you should get
angry with other people so there isn't a
right type it just means being calm or
patient or gentle so you'll be now
notice this is not saying you will be
completely that way you'll be more that
way this is a uh a term that's you'll be
more patient with but with everybody
pontes towards towards the whole world
if you can remember that there's one
other passage that I think is really
quite germane to this going back into it
where he says
what is uniquely human what is the idion
the specific thing about human beings is
to feel a faction felane in Greek for
people even when they make mistakes
right and now the word for making
mistakes here is quite interesting I
don't toss it literally means uh to like
stumble like you trip over something and
it can be extended into all sorts of
other mistakes so when people
screw up when they stumble and fall
well
still liking them still treating them as
human beings is part of what it means to
be a human being and how can we do that
well we can remind ourselves similar
things they act out of ignorance not
understanding things properly they do so
unwillingly and there's some other
considerations that he brings in here as
well some of them they haven't really
hurt you they haven't diminished your
ability to choose they're not they're
not cutting you off from knowledge of
what's good and bad or from doing what's
right and avoiding what's wrong unless
you let yourself get angry at them right
so it's much better for you to be calm
it's much better for you to feel pity
it's much better for you to continue to
feel and show affection to them even
when they're screw-ups even when they're
screwing up seems to be negatively
affecting you you can remind yourself
well in what really matters to me they
can't really damage me they can't lead
me astray I can choose these better
responses to them and he actually has
one other consideration here as well
which might strike is a little bit
morbid but it actually is is a great
perspective changer
you'll both be dead before long so how
important is the thing that you are
upset about probably in the grand scheme
of things as we say not that important
so you have the possibility
if you make sure to keep these things in
mind how it is that people in fact do go
astray you have the possibility of
choosing what sort of emotional
comportment you are going to have are
you going to allow yourself to get
outraged and angry or are you going to
remain calm affectionate and perhaps
even feeling pity or sympathy with the
other person that is Marcus thinks up to
us and he is giving us uh some
considerations that show us some really
useful techniques for making sure that
we wean ourselves away from that anger
response once and direct ourselves
instead towards more distinctively human
and rational Behavior